-I have so much to talk to you
about -- your show, your movie.
But I also want
to congratulate you.
You got engaged.
-I did.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I popped the question, man.
-You popped the question.
Thanksgiving, is that right?
-I did on Thanksgiving.
-Gotcha.
-It was kind of cheesy but --
-I think that's all right.
-It has special place in
my heart, that holiday now.
-I believe it.
Yeah.
-It was good.
-So, you bought
a ring and everything?
-Bought a ring.
-Did you get a ring back?
-No.
Because that's the weird thing,
you know, lesbian couples --
you got the masculine,
you got the feminine.
It's like, "I don't want, like,
a ring, that's, like,
a little too feminine.
So like, give me some sneakers."
-Oh, okay.
-So she got me some.
We were in Tokyo and she got me
some sneakers that you can
only get in Tokyo.
So I can literally be like,
"Y'all ain't got these, man."
[ Laughter ]
You know, you gotta go
to Tokyo to get these.
-That's great.
You mentioned that you have
a connection with Thanksgiving
forever now. You wrote --
won an Emmy for an episode
of "Master of None" you wrote,
which is like your
personal story of coming out.
-Which is not fun
for people, period.
-The coming-out story?
-Coming out is not fun, ever.
But when you're far away
from it, which you've done it,
then you can make jokes
and have fun
and call Angela Bassett
to come play a sweet version
of your mother.
You know, and have Kim Whitley
play a nice aunty.
You know, it's cool.
But, like, during the time,
it's, like, horrifying.
It's, like, the worst.
-Was it something that you --
How did it come about that it
became an episode of the show?
-Well, honestly, like,
Alan Yang, who is co-creator
of "Master of None,"
just asked me.
He's like,
"How did you come out?"
And I literally did a one-woman
show of the episode that
you guys now know is
Thanksgiving, and they were
like, "That's an episode, that's
an episode of 'Master of None.'"
I was like, "Really? I don't
think it's that interesting."
But they were like,
"No, you got to write it."
"You going to get it done."
And I was like,
"I got too much to do, man."
I got to do the Spielberg movie.
I'm still trying to get
"The Chi" green=lit.
And Aziz was just like, "Look,
I can't write that by myself."
That's a bad Aziz impersonation.
I don't want to do him dirty.
And go up a couple --
[ Laughter ]
But, he was like, "You know,
I can't write this by myself."
He's like,
"This is like your story.
I need you to help me tell it."
I'm so grateful that he
made me do it because
it changed my life.
-It was a fantastic episode
of television.
-Thank you so much.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How -- because you then had
to write it in London while
you were working on
"Ready Player One."
How was your --
Steven Spielberg?
What's that like,
to be around Steven Spielberg?
-Well, Steven Spielberg is
the Jewish father you didn't
know you needed.
-Yeah, okay.
-And he's amazing.
Like, I always say he's
a giant that doesn't
make people feel small.
-Uh-huh. That's a great way
of putting it, yeah.
-He's so cool.
He let's you play,
he let's you do your thing.
And even when it's your fault
when you mess up a take,
he don't make you think
it's your fault.
He's like, "That's my bad,
camera guy, bad camera guy!
You messed up!"
He's like,
"Now we got to do it again.
Okay, Lena, I apologize."
Like, he's so great.
Like, he just always makes you
feel right at home on the set.
-I know it just premiered
at South by Southwest.
I know people loved it,
great response.
For those who don't know, what
is the premise of the movie?
Because I heard it's described
as sort of a nerdgasm for all
the pop culture references
in this film.
-Yes, that's a fair assessment.
But it's also about -- like,
imagine social media times,
like, 200.
So it's like, you can literally
go to another planet and be
with your avatar picture.
If you want to think you're
Tupac, you can go be Tupac.
You know what I'm saying?
Muhammad Ali -- It's really
its own universe and
it's called the Oasis.
And people get to be whoever
they want in the Oasis.
But what happens is there's
this evil guy played
by Ben Mendelsohn who wants
to charge people to come
to the Oasis.
And the cool thing about
Ty's character and my character,
Olivia's character, all of us,
we want the Oasis free and cool
and a place people can chill.
But it's also about being
too caught up in escapism,
which I think to me is
a great metaphor.
Because you know, a lot of us
are on social media more than
we are involved in our lives.
And that, to me, is
at the root of it.
It's all about escapism is cool,
but we got to appreciate
real life, which is really nice.